なんか色がお連れのが早いな一回も染めてないんですけどあんな黒だったのにもう茶色
初めてそうで今日のお昼に東京からストーカーに帰ってきたんですけども明日の朝の新
幹線で結局ちょっとちょっとバタバタしてますが
明日も東京頑張って経営者
ん皆さんこちらご存知でしょうかたぶんねと文学ことが会社とかの人体測定か人大卒
程度に使われたと思うんですけどもこちら血圧計でございます暴論デジタル自動血圧計
あー見たことでトイレと思うんだけどもうは死んどるにこの中によりを突っ込むと血圧
がわかるというものでございますこれはねそれでかなり正確なものでそもそも血圧が
何かは分かりません
えっつってなんなんだろう実際血圧って何だろうってたそもそも血圧を測る意味が
わからんって血圧とあ血液ノア強くなって綱をされる力のことで隠蔵から送り出される
その欠席でしの量とか結果の方すごかによって決まりますよ
兄弟機の量が多ければ蹴っちゃってかかって結果通わなければ
結果な柔血管の硬さ
ねうーん俺は組んだら要するに血圧とはの簡単によって簡単に言いますと血液が全身に
幸を繰り出される時の結果にかかる圧力のことでございますでこの圧力がなんか基本値
以上の状態が続く状態を高血圧といってずっ釣りとかめまいとかが起きるらしいで
ございますだけ皆さんずっ釣りとかめまいとか肩こりを感じたし
と良かったら一回血圧測ってみたらいかがでしょうか
低話じゃなくて一つ電池3か昔よくやってたんだよな
ヘッダーとかかる検査の時に表立と高い数値を出した方が勝ちって言ってて血圧が高い
奴がなんか俺のなく強いというイメージがあった高やっぱ数値原野か戦闘力があると
みなされてて俺たちの仲間の誰かジャケットが高いや強いと言われていた
馬鹿丸出しだったら一回測ってみましょうまずいって真面目な
があります
うあーおれオレアーマー雨があー持ってるなんかよくわかんなくなっちゃったこれいい
んじゃねこれねこれでいっしょもなんか図っちゃってもいいかがありますが早速測って
みましょう背筋を伸ばす10%増と同じ高さにしだよ後尾に乗って重圧気失せ前によっ
ているはずですから開始
程よい締め付けが
彼に快樂を与えたはぁ方マって結構結構結構強なん
をきましたハイスコアねハイスコアハイスコ最高血圧が129倍で血圧が71でござい
ますそれが今やダンスコ
最高血圧130鯉状態て切っちゃったか85以上だと高血圧の可能性があるみたいです
129は至って正常な血圧みたいですね最低血圧がちょっと低いくらいです僕は変更
みたいですよかった本当に恋のちゃんと計って部の大事ですからね今回僕がやりたいの
は自らの力でこの最高桁の数値を上げるんじゃねぇ賀来北
思いますでなるべく僕の中での肺高血圧数値を叩き出してみようと思いますもう
めっちゃ話しますめっちゃ呼吸を上げてして僕が楽しんど動きが速いように見かけて
排出を叩き出していますいます
goo
ああああああ
ran
when んだ
me
阿部こちらのスコアになりました感じたああいう人がいるとおそらく低血圧でござい
ます次はメッツ可能振り絞ってやっています血管の太さとかも関係するみたいなので
めっちゃ力入れて測ってみたらどうなるかってみましょうぞ
どうぞ
うーん
わー
きたすごい使われサイコ系竜が181回てきたで138最強レベルですね
ちょまって本当に血圧上がったなぁ
108成長やばいすごいでしょ最強レベルです多分その心臓の鼓動とか家の中 f と
いうのはたぶん
運動したら金上がるともうちょっと寸胴してみましょう
ああああああ
ええええええ
なんてパンチョじゃあはスムーズ本じゃ
me
って4位まいりました井町もはぁんっ
ううっと158まで上がりましたなかなか良い思考じゃないでしょうか
玉俺はめちゃくちゃ運動をスタートに帰ってきてすぐ図って車てみて力を品 wald
多分何百4席がいくんじゃないかな血圧が次の運動の力を入れるの二つを合わせて
ちょっと
最後に最高ですかをたたきなさったのですか
苦しい
me
ちょっと待ってる
dan どっ
ni
goo
rar
ううううううっ
e 4
いいします
def